good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Thursday hope
everyone's having a great day it is a
Jackson Cloud OG original recipe finally
the girls are back together Audio Only
Extravaganza heyjacks I'm doing good how
are you Dern on your week without me so
far how have things been so terrible not
worth living not worth living not worth
pursuing just why do what I do when I
can't do daru it with a you you know
with it you uh yeah I agree I do agree
it looks like the episodes have been
really fun though they have yesterday
was like one of my favorite episodes of
all time Joey mass is just so funny and
he's like
he's on my level when it comes to like
speed talking [__] talking and also like
Niche pop culture references it was just
a joy to podcast with him everyone loved
it so it's things are going great
actually but I just miss you yeah I miss
you too well we're back together today
and it's like no time has passed how was
your day off days off did you get some
much needed relaxation did you go to the
doctor like what's up yes so I I rested
in the bed as you do on bed rest
um but it's not like I wouldn't say it's
relaxing
you know yeah because you're also still
a mother yeah there's still so much
going on like I'm still there's just
always something going on I've been like
watching Real Housewives of New Jersey
but I weirdly only get through like four
episodes a day which is a lot for a lay
person but like not a lot for a person
on bed rest no it's not like I just
fitted and got all caught up with the
second part of the reunion but like I've
been on bed rest for a week and like all
I've accomplished was like one season of
Real Housewives of one show yeah yeah by
the way that reunion was very good yeah
these reunions are getting infuriating
the cast members need to calm down and
yeah everyone was at yeah by the way the
Jersey reunion was giving Vanderpump
Vibes where like everyone was like
trying to have a sound bite and a moment
specifically Jennifer Aiden I just
expect more from Melissa like because
she is so
aware you know like Teresa's not
self-aware she doesn't know how she
comes off she really thinks like
everybody wants to hear what she has to
say all the time but like Melissa like
continuing to like get on that level
with her like while Andy's literally
screaming at them like I just expected
more from her because like she's better
than that she is better than that but
like acting you know like better than
that has really gotten her nowhere so
now she's stooping down to two trees
level but she doesn't need to act better
than that for like to take the high road
with Teresa it's like for the viewers
yeah it was painful it was semi-painful
yeah and then I'm gonna probably do
summer house next I guess I did summer
house because people are talking about
the reunion and I was halfway through
the season so I think I'll do that
that's exciting yeah so not super
restful but I've gotten some good
content and I've weirdly had like
a lot of work stuff like on my computer
you know like I've been working on my
computer a lot that's so good to be on
your computer working
Computing Computing working like there's
just always something going on on my
computer
that's the thing about computers man
they are crazy speaking of crazy we
haven't even been able to podcasts I
meant to talk about it yesterday with
Joey but I forgot what's going on in New
York is literally the craziest thing
it's the craziest thing I called you the
other day like two days ago oh my god
get over four air quality talk was cool
and I was Tuesday Morning Tuesday
Morning Tuesday morning because I saw
that the air quality on my weather app
they were like telling me like there's
bad air quality and you know I was like
feeling a little short of breath I
really was and I thought the two things
were related so I was just like
mentioning the air quality ever almost
like you're so dramatic I had no idea
what you were talking about and then
yesterday
it was apocalyptic in the city on
Tuesday morning you were talking to me
about it and I was like okay whatever
and then Tuesday night I left my house
to go to dinner and it really was so
crazy like my Uber driver was like in
pain and I was like what is going on he
was like it's 150 when it gets to the 3
400s it's really bad I'm like oh okay
yesterday Wednesday was so crazy when
Jax I recorded with Jax Taylor yesterday
when he got to the studio he was like
dripping like Snot tears coming out of
his eyes and then when I left to walk
home I was deeply unwell I put on a mask
and I was like wearing sunglasses I
really felt like a celebrity I was like
nobody knows that it's the girl from the
toast
yeah sure you know everyone was like
looking is that the girl from the toast
but they couldn't tell because that was
so covered up yeah that was sad for them
that they didn't get to see you in all
your glory I have to say actually
um when I was walking around in like my
sunglasses and mask I did actually meet
a toaster and she was so nice and she
was listening to the Joey Master episode
and it's because I was wearing a toast
mask like not me trying to be Incognito
with my brand on my mask stop
yeah and that helped you with the smog
it did by the way because Ben wasn't
wearing one and he was like Hawking up
loogies and like I was okay got it they
they can't get me to put a mask back on
like it's just not gonna happen it's not
gonna I'd rather smell the campfire
oh well I will say I'd rather have a
little s'mores by the fire this smell
I'm not bothered by even though my
clothes now stink like like Ash and like
burning charcoal which is not great
because I wore a cashmere sweater
yesterday but the smell is actually I
love that smell of like campfire wood
burning it smells like cute
um but the the the throat nose and eyes
are a real problem and of course the
cause you know Canada is burning is it's
not worth the smell yeah no no it's out
we're not asking for the smell I'm just
like trying to like be positive positive
with like a weird situation and I think
so bizarre it's so bizarre but I think
what's also really weird is like it
feels really scary to have like your
whole city like shrouded in Orange and
smoke yeah but the worst that I've seen
it's like if you're exposed to it for 24
hours it's like you smoke six cigarettes
which like
is bad
so it's like it's it's you're where it's
like a little fearful of the smog but
what is there to be fearful of like
tangibly
no it's just uncomfortable it's
uncomfortable and it's weird and it's
it's freaky looking today looks a lot
better but yesterday morning looked
better too I walked to work completely
fine yeah it didn't get like orange it
didn't get sepia tone until the
afternoon to like two three o'clock so
we'll see what happens today but it's
happening all over like the Northeast
and I've heard that there's now air
warnings in Virginia and Ohio like it's
spreading it's so crazy and this is just
something I never thought I'd see in my
lifetime yeah it's weird
to be part of like a phenomenal
moment and I think this happens like
much more commonly on the west coast
because California experiences wildfires
a lot so like the surrounding states
have experienced this sort of you know
over
spillover smog but this is not really
you know we're more of like a hurricane
Coast than a wildfire Coast yeah we have
our own issues and also I just think
seeing like these iconic buildings and
bridges like shrouded in Smoke it's like
these are really crazy images to see
that we've never seen before but in
California they see them once a year and
so it's not as jarring
so it's just like it's about us well
it's actually not it's ours
it's not even about us because the whole
thing is like it's happening in Canada
but just wishing Canadians well like no
like I feel like there's two things
happening like there's the cat in the
wildfires wishing them yes and then
there's everyone who's like getting
secondhand smoke who's yeah never
experienced such a thing and like we're
allowed to have our moment too for sure
the two are extrinsically linked yeah
but I feel I agree like this is I know
it's connected to Canada but we're all
just like walking around being like
what's going on yeah no we're making it
about us but I think we have every right
too because of how we got so impacted
the city look at and you know what again
not even though I did hear tomorrow it's
supposed to like this weekend actually
rain a ton which might clear it clear it
out and that's just again to make
everything about me God works mysterious
ways because we actually were supposed
to be away this weekend we were going to
take a family trip and then your bed
rest came and we had to cancel which was
totally fine but like we were gonna you
know be sad about our trip but if we
were out on our trip in this region we
were gonna take a road trip
um smoke rain it's for the best that we
weren't there yeah is it bad in the
suburbs like is it just I've looked at
the map it looks pretty bad like
everywhere but I'm only seeing pictures
of New York City is that just because
I'm here or because you know no one's
taking a picture of their backyard right
I am also only seeing things about New
York City but I have to imagine like an
hour or two outside the suburbs are
still
experiencing something yeah
so just crazy times that's like your
kind of air pollution update area air
pollution update
try and stay indoors if you can oh yeah
I canceled everything I did not go to
that concert last night mostly because
Margo like couldn't find tickets and
then at the last minute they were so
expensive and I didn't even really want
to go so she found that she went with
jazz like it was fine and like going
there would have been like one cigarette
right right when I could just like Vape
at home you know
um it says
cigarettes like measuring it by
cigarettes also it's like where are we
getting this information because last
night I was talking to Zach about it and
he was like he was like do you know if
you spend 15 minutes exposed to this
it's like smoking half a pack of
cigarettes I'm like I read that 24 hours
is six cigarettes so exact statistics
seems wrong yeah I know and I found my
tweet but tweeted by who yeah I know
like who well that's just that's a thing
in life like I read this tweet who is
the Tweeter right and how can we measure
just how can we measure but I do
appreciate them trying to like measure
your life
I do appreciate someone trying to show
us using like science fair tools yeah
what the air quality means it's giving a
cardboard tripod like science fair
project yeah but that's how we
understand science
so true hypothesis conclusion conclusion
so I think it's six cigarettes 24 hours
but I read that from someone who I don't
know who's probably uneducated and
someone who I wouldn't go to bat for I
don't know their name right you don't
even know their name yeah and I don't
even know but it sounded good
yeah yeah yeah
um so today's episode is obviously gonna
be all about the fog but it's also
really all going to be about Vanderpump
last night was the
um finale part three of the reunion we
got like the five minute spoiler we're
gonna get into it it's our first story
and tomorrow's episode which has already
been recorded because Jax Taylor was
leaving town in a in a rush and I was
like just get to the studio and he
showed up Brittany did not come they
took up their cut their trip short so
Britney went to go work and Jax was like
I have an hour if you have an hour and
he really made time for me and I'm so
grateful and he was amazing and you know
what I love Britney and I would
interview her separately too but I think
Jax and Brittany together
um I wouldn't have been able to get a
word in so I'm actually glad it was like
a one-on-one combo with Jax and I just
love Jax are you gonna call it Jackson
Claude well I was literally being like
it's Jackson Claude but not the one
you're used to yeah that's confusing
considering when you first started
saying Jackson Claude people thought you
were talking about Jax Taylor I titled
it um Jax Taylor mentions it all because
he just [__] went there he actually
there was like some big Revelations
um I of course just wanted to get an
update on him and Brittany so many
questions about him coming back to
Vanderpump it's clear he's very much
like back in the Bravo fold he hosted an
event you know for the finale last night
for Bravo
um but there was a lot of really
interesting tidbits he shared from
Schwartz he actually just had shorts on
his podcast and a lot of the um business
goings-ons when it comes to shorts and
Sandy's and we just talked about Banner
public from start to finish OG Seasons
update on his marriage he's so happy and
he's like such a good dad and I honestly
at the end when he was talking about I
said I'm like I never would have
expected you know we know you from TV
you're the most involved like devout dad
and I could just tell you like love
being a dad and he was talking so much
about fatherhood at the end like I think
he got a little choked up it was really
sweet I've always been like a jack Stan
honestly he's always
genuinely been so nice to me in person
like and I feel like I met him for the
first time like eight years ago maybe
seven years ago and he's I didn't know
he said crazy on TV but I feel like we
got to see a nice side of Jax on the
podcast and I'm excited for people to to
hear it and watch it we filmed it too
yeah I feel like Jax is one of those
people who when he's on TV like he is
playing a part it's not completely
divorced from like who he is as a person
like there are parts of him it's not two
separate people but like when you meet
him in person you realize that he's like
a real person that he also knows what
he's doing in terms of entertainment
value like it's not like you're sitting
down with the guy in the chunky sweater
all the time no no and that's what he
said and I think that's what like a lot
of his
um resentment towards Sandoval is like
Sandoval's been in this eight-year
relationship and they've had problems
and Sandoval has made sure that those
problems do not make air and it's like
Jax is sitting here he had to deal with
you know his infidelity on his fiancee
like Jax and all the Christian everyone
like really bled out for the show and
was so honest and he said you know of
course there's so many benefits you know
we were able to buy a house and like we
got famous but it's not without putting
in some work and so for all this to be
blowing up in Sandoval's face I think
it's like really gratifying for a lot of
the people who who have been there and
and got to watch him become the owner of
Tom Tom and do all these things without
doing that yeah but also I think
Sandoval now in hindsight is extremely
regretful and you saw he tried to change
course this season by airing their
issues because if he had a
well-documented all of the issues over
the years their breakup eight years
later wouldn't have been so
destabilizing for the fans but because
they put on this perfect relationship
that we never had to worry about and
then the crime was so egregious he made
it even worse for himself
100 and then this season he's like well
Ariana doesn't like me sometimes and
it's like right bro what you're like
trying to like climb up a mountain of
like uh chipping away at your
relationship and that's just not going
to cut it yeah like he was trying to
retroactively like plant seeds yeah and
it wasn't working we're not buying it
yeah so just be authentic next time so
I'm very excited for tomorrow's episode
to come out like there's stuff there's
some stuff about Tom Sandoval like being
on tour in Kentucky and what that meant
like for Brittany it was really
interesting I don't want to spoil that
it's like hard for me to sit here and
not just tell you guys everything he
said but it comes out tomorrow sorry
okay cool you open early in the AM you
know I'm it's already edited and stuff I
love doing this is what like other
podcasters do like they get to record on
a Tuesday and upload it on a Friday so
they get time to like edit with us like
it's you know once we finish recording
it's a race to get it up so people can
get it as soon as possible you don't
have time to go to the bathroom right so
I'm experiencing like real podcasting
like as other people do it and so
recording on a Wednesday for a Friday
release oh my God I'm so relaxed yeah no
it's just not in our the cards for us
no no that's because we're so authentic
and that's kind of our cross to bear
we're so authentic we're so timely also
Imagine talking about the air pollution
on a Tuesday and dropping it on Friday
right air quality changes our
authenticity is our Achilles
heel you know what the air quality
reminds me of that episode of the crown
with the London Fog
is
just feeling like I'm in the London Fog
well the fog is reminding me of Chile
and last night I was like this is such a
chilly night like there's this kind of
apocalyptic Vibe everyone's staying
indoors it's getting like snowstorm
right yeah yeah Ben was so anti-chilly
it was like actually really jarring it
was probably the first time in our
relationship he was like I'll make a
chili like for you I hate when he does
that like actually the other day Ben did
the rudest [__] thing he made a chili
for you no no we're so we're out to
lunch we're out to lunch and Ben I know
like in the last two weeks he's been
like grinding on his you know keto
season he's been like really healthy and
I never want to be a bad influence so we
sit down at lunch and we both are
getting salads and when you're getting a
salad like you also need like like a
side of fries or like something no yeah
a starter maybe even like a tuna tartare
if you're really healthy no so like I
wanted like a margarita pizza for like
an appetizer like one of those you know
little ones and then we both have salads
like I thought that was like a good
balance and he's like no I don't want
pizza I'm like oh he said but get it and
I was like no because it's so big and
then I'll just literally eat the whole
thing there's no need for me to eat a
whole pizza when I have a full entree
coming he's like okay actually you know
I get the pizza like I'll do pizza I was
like oh amazing
the pizza arrives and he like had pulled
one over on me he's like no I'm not
eating the pizza I just wanted you to
have it so I literally ate the whole
pizza
and it was so it was actually it was
upsetting
I don't know turdy I don't know if I I'm
on you don't agree I think it's like
really sweet that he pretended that he
wanted so that you would order it
because he knew that you wanted it but
that you wouldn't have ordered it
without him
no but like I didn't like the person I
was when I had the pizza to myself and
that's what I didn't want to happen but
he made sure that it did
I think he was just trying to make you
happy
not in the way that I wanted it to
damn this is like some serious mental
gymnastics I know like I couldn't tell
if he was being really sweet or just
trying to like set me up to eat a whole
pizza like that okay well that's wrong
if you really think that was his
intention no of course not he just like
bends for me Ben knows like food equals
love and like food equals I'm being
taken care of and food equals like my
wife is happy and being nice to me oh if
my wife only eats a salad she's not
gonna be nice to me no but like we went
to this one place you know I don't like
salads but there's about three salads in
the city that I actually love and we we
literally Trek to Uptown 20 well like 20
blocks to go to this place because I
wanted to be healthy and I'm like okay
well if I'm gonna be healthy I can only
go to two or three spots that I can
stomach the lettuce at and so by the
time my my salad came I like wasn't even
into it because I ate a whole ass Pizza
like it was so backwards
I'm sorry that this happened to you and
I'm not saying the name of the place
because it's always so busy and I can
never get a table so sorry I'm keeping
this one to myself what if you said the
name and then all of a sudden like
you're a celebrity there and they're
like sending you merch and giving you
reservations
sometimes that happens
so true but I'm not risking it okay
I have a good now like it's good it's a
neighborhood spot like I'm good okay
well I don't think Ben did something
wrong also sometimes it's like if I'm
not eating for you know unhealthy like
I'm really trying to be good like I
still want other people to like you get
kind of like Joy from other people
eating good do you know what I mean no
if I'm miserable We're All in This
Together I kind of like can eat
vicariously through you no I can't just
sit like if there's a pizza on the table
there's no way I'm not having a bite
that's why it's like ordering it is such
a big deal because if it's here I'm
eating it if it's not here I will move
on
got it and like you know I'm trying to
get my summer bod in check and Ben was
just basically setting me up is what I'm
trying to say
so then he didn't make a chili
oh yeah that's what I was saying he was
like I'll make you a chili but like I
don't want it so we didn't make we
didn't have chili it just felt like such
a waste of a of a smoky afternoon
you should have made the chili and then
brought me the other half
hundred percent Harry loves chili
yeah
yeah and you can tell that to Ben
yeah Harry loves chili
and how is Harry faring I'm assuming you
know all of his activities have been
canceled yeah his outdoor activities
have been canceled he's staying home
mostly
um so that's like you know Annoying to
be all cooped up but yeah this air
quality man
no I would never subject Harry to this
you know
apocalyptic Vibe yeah yeah plus for me
with the like I'm already short of
what is it with pregnancy like you are
short of breath yeah like it's harder to
breathe already
um but I did have to go out yesterday
and
it was okay
you went out like a little early kind of
no I was in the after I was like dead
afternoon oh it's it's so crazy you guys
like I can't yeah so crazy
crazy I think we should dive in because
our first story is the Vanderpump
reunion that really like I waited around
all day I was so excited it was like I
got showered like I did everything
before me and Ben had dinner in bed it
was like it was really just a very
exciting night oh we were excited too
obviously my husband is number one skin
of all obsessor but he was like falling
asleep like he kind of like
I was like you're gonna miss it he's
like I'm kind of over it I was like I
know he's not used to this night
yeah he's not used to like the Bravo's
like signature drawing out of [__] they
took too much from him he couldn't give
anything more
I was like disinterested until James
came on and like literally every time he
came on gonna be like
like scream laugh and like scare the
[__] out of me he loves James that's so
funny Zach also didn't know about the
last five minutes thing and I was like
apparently something happens at the last
five minutes so that like he held on to
that and when they were like taking the
group picture at the end he's like
what's got what happened I was like the
group picture was so weird so weird I
was like just keep waiting and then the
last five minutes happened let's get
into it let's get into it the fast five
stories that you need to know
and the first step stories that you need
to know are brought to you by modern
fertility for a lot of us the start of
the New Year feels like the right time
to schedule doctor's appointments check
in with where you're at health-wise but
what about your reproductive Health
we've always been big fans of planning
ahead so like scheduling trips plotting
out our next career moves but we never
thought much or at least I didn't about
planning for kids and that's why modern
fertility was created it's an easy and
affordable way to test your fertility
hormones at home with a simple finger
prick mail it in with a prepaid label
and you'll get personalized results
within six days you'll get insight into
your hormone levels like your ovarian
reserve which is basically if you if you
have like more or fewer eggs than the
average woman your age and you'll also
get other important factors that can
impact your fertility the results go
deep into what every hormone means and
you can also download the results to
review with your doctor for next steps
traditional hormone testing at a clinic
can cost over six hundred dollars but
modern fertility tests the same general
set of hormones and it costs only a
hundred and seventy nine dollars plus if
you go to modernfertility.com toast
you'll get an additional 20 off your
test you can get reimbursed for the test
through your FSA or your HSA so if you
want kids today or maybe one day in the
future clinically sound information
about your body can help make the
decision that's right for you you know
having data is never a bad decision like
having insights into what's going on
you'll never regret so right now modern
fertility is offering our listeners 20
off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that means
your test will cost 159 dollars which is
a fraction of what it would cost at a
fertility clinic get 20 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that's
modernfertility.com
toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by manscaped Father's Day is creeping up
on us faster than a creepy Uncle at a
family reunion and if you haven't gotten
a gift for your dear old dad yet you're
in luck manscaped has got your back and
your dad's balls trust us your dad will
be thanking you for keeping his balls in
check and hey it's not just a gift for
him you and your mom will appreciate the
results too if you know what we mean so
don't wait any longer use code toast to
check out for 20 off in free shipping
your dad will thank you for the most
memorable Father's Day gift ever so so
manscaped is the only men's brand that's
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and they just launched their lawnmower
4.0 so imagine surprising your dad with
a sleek well-designed and optimized body
hair trimmer that says your balls will
thank you on the box their fourth
generation trimmer features a Cutting
Edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their Advanced Skin
safe technology
they have tons of other products too
like the lawnmower 4.0 which is another
great trimmer they have great like skin
care they have crop preserver ball
deodorant they have cologne they have
ball wipes ball toner for other girls
listening you'll appreciate this part
manscaped products are cruelty free
Power bin free dye free and vegan you
can get 20 off in free shipping with
code toast at manscape.com so get your
dad a gift they will you know that they
will use or your husband too by the way
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscaped.com
m-a-n-s-c-a-p-e-d.com use code toast
don't forget that you came from from
your dad's balls this year show your
original home some love with manscaped
again that is code toast
thank you turdy you're welcome our first
story Vanderpump Rules recap the
Vanderpump Rules bombshell revealed in
the explosive final reunion episode so
we sat down with Raquel we went through
the story The Affair the this the that
only to then find out that a lot of
everything they said was alive was a lie
Raquel did her final interview and
what's so interesting is when that when
the finale aired and Markel had done
like an interview
they only put one clip from what she
said and we said like where is the rest
of that interview like what else is this
girl saying yes she had no like sidebar
commentary literally just had like one
and it's like but you've got to sit down
like where is this stuff here it was
where she unraveled everything that
Sandoval had told her to say pretty much
you know debunking this whole thing that
it was a one night stand and then an
affair a few months later it was more
linear it was linear
but like it was linear and I guess the
thing that they really wanted to keep
from coming out was that not only did
they have sex in in Tom and Ariana's
house but it was the weekend that Ariana
was away burying her [__] grandfather
which like takes it to another even more
sorry grandmother even more depraved
level and that was like the thing that
Tom just really wanted to keep from
getting out
um it was such a bizarre roller coaster
of emotions and she seemed um truly
Manic and and the fact that we know for
the last couple of weeks she's been in a
mental health facility is not surprising
given what she's been going through and
then also that last shred of footage
from her like that's clearly a person
going through something and it was
actually a little scary and it
definitely made me sympathetic towards
her
um I think I don't think she meant it to
but I do think that last set of
interview was hey like the first time we
saw her feel any remorse like at the
reunion she was so robotic and Tom was
really emotional but nothing he says
nobody's buying no and first of all now
we know he was lying through his teeth
so how are you so emotional and too like
he's just acting like he's just do doing
and saying like whatever he thinks will
help him get to the other side of this
so at least when she like wasn't
emotional it's like well at least she's
not pretending to be something that
she's not like I'd rather hear from her
and just like she's very matter of fact
than him and his lies and like his
dramatic overtures it's so crazy that
they went to these lengths to
hide that they had sex in the house on
the grandma's funeral like after the
whole hearing the entire story and just
the whole relationship like nothing even
shocks me about these two and the only
thing that actually shocks me now is
that they were still lying like I had
chosen to believe like what what what
they said at the reunion I was taking at
face value because like the lie was out
so you know and like the reunion is the
place to like bear it all and there was
and everyone was unsaid everything and
like there's all these rumors coming out
so like now is the time to like set the
record straight in the least that you
could give us and that you could give
Ariana is the truth so I really just
gave them the benefit of the doubt that
like when he said something that it was
more or less the truth because literally
what's the point of lying like you're
already [__] no and now Raquel's like
five minute thing at the end really
undid everything Sandoval said about
everything not just the timeline but the
fact that there wasn't a girl in Chicago
and then what about the girl after the
bar like right everything now is there's
like a seed of doubt and he's every
because he's a liar and he tried to
break up with Ariana like I I kind of
believed that just because
that's what a person should have been
wanting to do you know so I'm just like
well that makes sense yeah he tried but
it just like it never it's hard to break
up with someone that you actually care
for I just believed him like because
that's what I do I believe uh he's a
liar liar pants on fire now I can't it
undoes everything that he said at the
ring and he's even further back than
when he started and for Raquel I do
think that this has made people a little
more sympathetic towards her one because
we just like appreciate her telling the
truth yeah but two like she clearly had
been very coached and she looks like a
victim she does look like a victim a
victim of like a mass manipulator like
borderline abuser
um and I think
that last five minutes left the door
slightly ajar for Raquel to be a part of
the future of the show and slammed the
door in Sandoval's face because if no
one will film with you then you're not
you can't be a part of the show and I
feel like at that point the last person
who would have filmed with Sandoval is
Schwartz but I know Schwartz was just on
um Jax's podcast and Schwartz is like
definitely changing his tune like
finally after years and years of being
thrown onto the bus because of his
friendship was Sandoval and everything
in his life going to [__] because of his
relationship with Sandoval I do think
he's starting to like maybe see the
light now well I think for Schwartz this
is pivotal because one Schwartz was the
one who said the affair wasn't linear
and
Schwartz has a little more credibility
than Sandoval so when he says yes there
was an affair and I knew about it but it
was only I only found out at this time
and it happened in this way we all kind
of believe Schwartz he made Schwartz
look like
such a an [__] also the fact that
they were hooking up in Mexico when he
was encouraging Schwartz to hook up with
Raquel like that would just make me
question my friendship in general but
also like Schwartz put himself out there
as like a spokesperson for Sandoval and
he wasn't even working with true
information that's not like that's
goodbye
yeah I mean I just don't know what has
to happen in the Schwartz and Sandoval
relationship for Schwartz to like be mad
I think this this is a betrayal of
Schwartz whereas him making mistakes in
his personal life like true friendship I
guess you know if he's closest with
Sandoval
you stand by some people stand by their
friends so yeah I I it's not what I
would do if I wear shorts but I
understand like he's gonna support his
friend in his hard time but he betrayed
Schwartz with these lies
even on Mark Chapman's live last night
Lala wasn't like going so hard after
Raquel when they were talking about that
like last five minutes she was like I
was confused I felt bad for her I think
like this definitely and I don't think
she's not a master manipulator of her
own PR Raquel she's been handling this
whole thing incredibly poorly so I think
it was completely authentic and in turn
her authenticity like actually helped
her yeah and also like an exposing
Sandoval further like okay so we can
bury him deeper in the ground but we'll
you know we'll allow it there's an equal
elevation for Raquel
but and honestly I think if you really
want to want an example of how clearly
um
delusional and and nuts Sandoval made
Raquel then you can look to the
conversation with the statement Raquel
made to the producer when she said at
one point you know I thought about
asking them if we could be in a throuple
and she said it completely seriously
like I think Sandoval was really leading
her to believe that like he loved her he
was ending things with Ariana that like
what they were doing was on some way had
a path to being kosher like even if it
meant being in a throw up like she's
also very naive and she was acting
selfishly and stupidly
he targeted her she's like a perfect
person for him she's very young she's
very vulnerable she's very easily
manipulated and she was clearly having
some sort of like crisis of self crisis
yes exactly and he like pounced on her
at the perfect time like that's what a
true and that's what Lala was saying
everyone thought she was being dramatic
when she was comparing him to Randall
and saying he's a dangerous person but
like no look at literally look at Raquel
like shaking being manic literally
spewing nonsense in that last five
minutes like that's what a crazy person
did to her yeah
there are so many red flags and I I hate
when everyone like diagnoses her and
it's like throwing out all these like
labels for her and Sandoval like you
know uh like
whatever we don't know we don't know
like she needs to
get help and I do think that she were to
get the right kind of help she shouldn't
be on the show anymore because like look
what this show did to her like look how
this show and the fame and getting
caught up in it allowed her to act in
her life like if she really wants to
prioritize like leading a good life
balanced this is not the the venue for
her so I don't need her to go get mental
health health so that she can start
filming again yeah you know like if she
really cares about the quality of her
life she should not be on the show she
started out at what seemed to be like
just a sweet quiet shy pageant girl and
it just like led her down this path of
sin
yeah and you don't need to go back to
that yeah and I think her and I know
she's really close to their family and I
believe her family like hates the show
does not want her to be on it is doing
everything they can to like keep her
away from it so I do think there
actually is a path for her on the show
now like seeing everything fully and
completely but I don't think it would be
the right thing for her yeah yeah not in
a me not in a real way
but also we didn't get any Clarity on um
uh Tom and Raquel's like relationship
status they said they were in love so I
think they were together when that
filmed yeah I don't know she obviously
had a crisis of course she got things
she said all the truths like I'm sure he
was mad at her
and then she bounced
to she's been away for a while you know
this third part obviously was the best
part I still was getting annoyed
especially and James had said something
he was like why are we keeping talking
about like okay yeah and there's a
conversation to be had about like James
and Lala [__] and you know is that
hypocritical and all that that's part
one and part two fodder by the time and
it was the end of the day for them and
James like why are we still talking
about this Tom Raquel is finally here
like could we talk about Raquel
yeah I I don't know I feel like they
wound up taking what more time
complaining about the fact that they
were asked about these things where like
in the whole cycle of the group like in
the ecosystem like lala hates Raquel
because of like uh scandaval and James
but Lala he I mean Raquel hates Lala
like she did sleep with her boyfriend
like it's it's not completely irrelevant
and instead of no but it should have
been addressed earlier sure but like
instead of just like completely just
answer the question and move on like I
feel like with any question that was
asked about something I'd had to not do
with Scandal it wasn't a conversation it
was a question and an answer yeah so
just answer it and let's move on and
we'll get back to the task at hand don't
like you don't all of you get a pass for
poor Behavior because Scandal you know
what I mean and I feel like there was
probably a lot of that this season like
I think that there was a whole season of
story lines that
went nowhere because they started to
prioritize this
um
so maybe someone had a bad season and we
didn't even know
and they got a pass like I think you can
answer for like you did sleep together
when you guys were together it's not
totally irrelevant to this storyline
just explain yourself and also because a
lot of the fans say that like people
will say lala can't say anything she
slept with James so Lala what do you say
to that
another major bombshell that I think
everyone is talking about is Tom's like
incredibly disgusting and real comment
about Ariana when Tom Andy basically
asked you know have you slept with
anyone besides Raquel and Ariana was
like yeah he slept with me and he goes I
mean you didn't take your T-shirt off it
was really hot
I literally could vomit
so and I feel like that's like where his
mask slipped it was a long day he had
his whole act on crying yada Yana victim
victim and for a second he just got like
pissed and the real him came out and he
put the mask back on to like come right
afterwards but for a second we like
really saw the the disgusting person he
is who he tries to hide from us I
thought not that the mask slipped but
again he was trying to sew the seed of
like this bad relationship and in some
because he's like a [__] up person he
thought that he would get Sympathy by
saying like he thought that like people
would be like oh I guess it wasn't that
hot because she had her t-shirt because
he doesn't know what's right and what's
wrong
something about her they must have seen
the screener because they had a t-shirt
up for sale before the episode was even
over it's like a cool cartoon of Ariana
and it says [__] me in this t-shirt yeah
well no not that they saw the episode
but I think everyone knew that comment
would be like Central right right they
experienced it yeah so um everyone's
really like making merch with everything
going on
um actually a big conversation that um
Jax and I had about how like you know
this whole thing obviously is terrible
but it's been so good for business for
everyone in podcasts yeah like in in all
sectors yeah and I think in so many
organic ways like of course podcast it's
good for the show the ratings like you
know before this like where was the show
even going like that's really good but
then it also feels like there are these
huge cash grabs that are a little more
far-fetched
um and as I mean Ariana's on the cover
of Glamor magazine did you see that yeah
that was I just pulled that up to talk
about that the cheese on the cover of
Glamor magazine and she talked about how
she um will continue to capitalize on
the Scandal because she she never wants
to worry about money this is Ariana's
thing to like she should capitalize and
laugh all the way to the bank and by the
way that was an interesting conversation
that that uh Schwartz brought up and I
didn't think he was bringing it up in a
malicious way but I think the question
came off rude he was like you know
obviously this is terrible but like the
world is behind you and like Brands and
everything like does it help and it came
off rude because he doesn't know how to
[__] talk but it was a good question
and I think she was offended by it and
she said it's literally been the only
thing like that's been getting me
through this portrayal but I I was
actually pretty pleased that he brought
it up yeah and we talked about that when
she was on Watch What Happens live
because Andy said like you're talking
about going on watch uh Dancing with the
Stars like your whole life has changed
she's in all these commercials for these
huge Brands
um I do think it is a silver lining at
the time I had said like I don't know
would you rather have like this
security of like having a boyfriend and
a best friend and like a whole
Village Life versus like okay you have
all these endorsements but you don't
have that anymore but the thing is she
never had that to begin with like those
people yeah were not real people so I'd
rather know the truth and have the money
you know what's so interesting is you
know we see the commercial every time
Vanderpump is on the Bic Razors she did
one yesterday with Duracell because he
was like when was the last time you
bought batteries and so she did and
she's been doing all these commercials
like really big Brands and whatever and
she films them all in her house
which I find so interesting like not one
of them has been at like a studio or
anything oh well I think one they're
like home brands
yeah and two her house is Iconic from
the show like we know her house
yeah
I don't think that's weird
I do also because if they own the house
together when you like use your house as
a set like you get paid by like the
location manager because they would be
paying for like any it's like just
Thomas are you positive it's her house
or just yes a set house
oh maybe it's a set house yeah that has
like the vibe of her you know it
literally looked like her house
well I think that maybe they did a good
job getting you to think she's in her
home
that's a good call that's a good call I
there's no no red flags go up for me I'm
just curious about it
uh what else
I mean there is another episode next
week and they're like really hyping it
up I'm like Secrets Revealed well I
think next episode is all the footage
from the season that we would have seen
if not for scannable so just like people
being you know
reality stars reality right it probably
will actually be one of the good
versions of Secrets reveal just because
it's like things they didn't have enough
time there's not enough time in the day
for all the footage they have so it'll
probably just be like good drama um I
don't know that I'll watch it but
yeah
yeah so I mean this is technically like
the end of the season but they do pick
up filming like pretty soon and if
Bravo's smart they'll get cameras
rolling as soon as possible
um and I don't think this is the end of
like you know things that'll come out
and people talking about it because it's
really it's a fluid situation it's like
still going on we don't even know if
they're together even though Lala said
on watch Robin's live like she doesn't
believe them to be together and she
believes Tom has already moved on
that's an amazing question
one girl was accused of being his
girlfriend and she literally deleted her
Instagram like that's how ashamed she
was of even being associated with him
yeah I'm starting to feel like they're
not together she if she really is is
serious about her mental health and like
just getting to a place of like feeling
like a good person again like after if
she really feels the way that she said
that she did she can't be with Tom
no and I really couldn't fathom them
them not being together before I saw
those last five minutes because she she
did betray him technically like they had
an agreement and
you don't do that to someone you're like
aligned with you
yeah that's a big betrayal in a
relationship even if we're grateful for
it right so I don't think they're
together
interesting yeah
okay well that's a wrap on scandaval
really I'm so sad until next time
yeah until next time but I do think now
people are going to do more podcasts
like the embargoes have stopped so
they'll probably be like more things
trickling out but again it's impossible
to weed through as just a fan like all
the rumors versus like there's so many
rumors and their things that cast
members actually said that sounds like
rumors and I don't know what's what I
can't listen to every podcast and I
can't like follow every Bravo account or
even one of them so yeah yeah so I'm out
Scandal out
deuces
okay ready for our next story I guess
even though there's nothing else worth
talking about no there really really
isn't but what is it Adam DeVine was on
a podcast saying him and his wife
witnessed a man get gunned down outside
his 2.6 million dollar house I [__]
love Adam DeVine and his wife like so
Random they're like a celebrity couple I
always check in on they're like so
stable and so cute and both so good
looking well like they've been through
something recently because he revealed
the chilling moment he and his wife
Chloe Bridges saw a man gunned down
outside their Hollywood Mansion
appearing at a live taping of the this
is important podcast the Pitch Perfect
star recalled seeing a man shot to death
from across the road
he said this is a true scary thing that
just happened so across the street they
were running this like crazy poker game
people were rolling up in Lamborghinis
and Bentleys and rolls royces and [__]
and like old guys who for sure [__]
prostitutes and play cards and I see
these dudes and it's like fun to sit and
watch so me and my my wife were sitting
up on our balcony and like this looks
crazy
he said to the audience this is where it
gets sad he recalled um when a man was
suffered multiple gunshot wounds at 2
A.M he said someone was murdered there
Jesus yeah the podcast hosts were taken
aback with his recollection calling the
situation sad before adding you know a
real person no longer with us but this
was like a story that was in the news of
like someone who was shot
in Hollywood that's so crazy witnessed
it
oh man well I'm glad ever well not the
guy but I'm glad you know Adam and his
wife were were unharmed
um that's so scary that's like when when
you become like so invested in your
snooping and then you see something you
don't want to say yeah
his wife is so pretty you know she's
Donna Ladonna from The Carrie Diaries
like most iconic bully in high school
history no I know you're obsessed with
her I never watch Carrie Diaries what it
was like a you and snitch thing I was
kind of like wouldn't let me watch with
you that's Austin Butler's like claim to
be no I know you have to watch it by the
way there's only one season and it's so
good and you're on bed rest add it to
your list
um my list is getting long I I'm also
gonna watch Love and Death Zach and I
watched a trailer we thought it looked
really good and then we went to sleep
you will absolutely hate Carrie but it
tracks because Carrie is the worst yeah
Carrie's still carry right right
technically you'll hate her but I love
Anna Sophia Robb so I think I might like
her I'm so glad you just brought that up
where's Anna Sophia Rob
I think she's doing living her best life
as the kids say
you know when I was a student at the
University of New York New York
University she was one of my classmates
I didn't know that actually she wasn't
like a classmate because we didn't have
any classes together but I would always
see her in like the lecture buildings
she was a student while you were a
student yeah and I guess that makes her
classmate actually does it yeah she's a
co-ed she was a co-ed yeah I don't think
you actually have to have class
because we didn't I think she was
studying something like really random
and Niche Cole and Dylan Sprouse were
also my classmates but they were also
studying like he was Cole was studying
um archeology I remember everybody knew
like everything about them and Dylan was
who what was he studying like video
games or something like really weird and
like Electric
damn
photography actually I don't know for
sure photography for a lot of
celebrities no Cole was archeology like
I remember there was a girl in one of my
recitations who was like in a class and
they did like a dig together
and what did they find
not much
I'm searching Cole Sprouse college major
geographic information systems in
archeology like I said now Google Dylan
okay
and then that was like one of the perks
video game designs oh my God I you're a
loser a freak I am a loser Anna Sophia
Ross let me think let me think hold on
let me see if I can remember
I feel like it was like English or like
literature or something
it's not coming up like it did for the
Sprouse Brothers
what about the streis brothers The
Strife Brothers have majored in cuteness
and
minored in scratchies
when Sophia Rob is married she got
married in the Catskills last year yes I
did know that and she wore like a
beautiful like scarf around her neck it
was so different she's so like Old
English you know yeah she was genuinely
born in the wrong time period She has
like a face of like like a woman from
the 50s
yes and no
no I think just yes
okay okay I'll let I'll
you let it slide I'll let it slide
she gives like you know
like like a 50s vibe
yeah no not wrong
yeah no I would say right
[Laughter]
right
correct true that I can't believe I was
right on two out of two Sprouts Brothers
I'm genuinely I'm I'm actually
embarrassed like it would be cool if it
wasn't so losery
I knew that I was right about Cole
Sprouse but I really felt like I was
just guessing madillen video games like
I can't
oh my God like that's really creepy
honestly that was one of like the very
few Perks at NYU like yeah there were
rats in your dorms but there were celebs
in your classrooms
yeah I believe Carly Kloss was also a
student at the grad school while I was
there
oh no Emma Watson and Claudia ashrae was
a student there yeah but like nobody
cared and that's why I hated it there so
true toxic environment for you I had
like 500 000 followers on Instagram at
the time and like not one person gave a
shred of a [__] and I would walk around
be like you guys know who I am
and they were like no actually we don't
and we don't want to
quite literally that hurts
deeply are you ready for our next story
no
no is it the next story that's brought
to you by betterhelp per chance yes tis
it is so easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you and never
take a moment to think about what you
need from yourself you know we are wives
we are mothers we are friends and
sisters so we're always looking out for
those in our lives but it's so important
to look out for number one when we spend
all of our time giving it can leave us
feeling stretched thin and burned out
therapy can give you the tools that you
need to find a more Balanced Life so you
can keep supporting others without
leaving yourself behind so if you've
been thinking about starting therapy why
don't you give better help a try it's
therapy done entirely online it's
designed to be convenient to be flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire you'll get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists at any time
for no additional charge so it's done
entirely online which means once you get
matched with a therapist you can
communicate with them via text message
phone call video chat whatever you're
most comfortable with and I think what's
great about it because it's done online
a it's accessible it's affordable but
also so you know a lot of people who
have been in therapy know that when you
get matched with a therapist for the
first time it's not always a perfect
match so sometimes you have to switch it
up and in person that can be awkward you
know the waiting rooms a lot of like
awkward social interactions better help
gets rid of all that find more balance
with better help visit betterhelp.com
toast to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t today's episode is brought to
you by Thrive Market Thrive Market is
our go-to for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting it all quickly shipped to our
doorstep is a huge Time Saver Jax you
might as well be like the number one
user of Thrive Market not only when
you're in Florida but also while you're
here tell me about your your journey as
being a Thrive Market member where you
save money on every single order well I
love Thrive Market it's groceries online
which is just greater than groceries not
online and going through the store and
like looking for the exact product and
reading all the ingredients like instead
you can like just search by
dietary preference what you're looking
for and now on bed rest like I'm
definitely not going to the grocery
store so I just order the groceries for
the house Zach gets them puts them away
I have such great healthy options and I
know that like whatever he wants to
prepare is going to be really good for
us I actually did a haul it's live now
on my Instagram if you want to go watch
it uh a haul of products that we got
from Thrive Market you're gonna be
really influenced not only does thrive
Market save us money but they also save
us time the filters on their website are
fabulous they have over 70 so whether
you're looking for certified gluten-free
snacks non-toxic cleaning Essentials you
can basically curate your own shopping
experience with the click of a button
when you join Thrive Market you're also
helping a family in need with their one
for one membership matching program you
join and they give so join Thrive market
today and get 30 off your first order
plus a free 60 gift go to
thrivemarket.com the toast for 30 off
your first order plus a free 60 gift
that's
t-h-r-i-v-e market.com slash the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast great
great great Market
great great
our next story Megan Maroney is talking
about the Morgan Wallen dating rumors
she says quote I won't hint at who my
songs are about again so Megan Maroney
is booked in busy she won her first CMT
award in April released her debut album
Lucky in May and is on the road with
Brooks and Dunn before headlining her
own tour but when she first released her
now Smash Hit Tennessee orange fans were
clicked to link her to the country
singer Morgan Wallen after the two
started commenting on each other's posts
and he then released a song called
Tennessee fan which is so like mirrors
mirrors so many of her lyrics I'd like
I'm obsessed with both songs with both
artists and with this story and like I'm
just trying to like every time I listen
to each of their albums I'm like trying
to figure out ways that it's about each
other
um yeah but ultimately I don't actually
think it is well in an interview with um
SiriusXM in November she did confirm
that the t-shirt that she was wearing
for the promotional art for the song it
belonged to Morgan Wallen okay so she
said the highway interview everyone I
think saw it as me trying to be Sly but
I'm like I'm actually just having a
panic attack I was honestly shocked that
I even said it was his shirt but I guess
since he had already confirmed it with
another poster thing that he did I was
like yeah sure it's his shirt so
she said that's all there is to the
story but now
um she will not be talking about any of
what her songs are about or who they're
about because she was just like so shook
up by it but like how do you end up with
someone's shirt
okay here's what I think in a
platonic way
so
I think that like they Morgan Wallen was
like being generous and like helping
hype her up and like letting people
think that and like leaving comments I
think they're friends like maybe they're
on the same record label they have some
sort of connection maybe they have the
same manager or something
um and I think he was like more than
happy to lend his celebrity to like lift
up this new female artist like yeah sure
let people think I'm dating this hot
young thing it's a good Rising Tides
rise all shines you know
um and I do think maybe it was his shirt
not like in a sexy way
um it was his shirt
you know what I'm saying but like not in
a sexy way not like she you know they
[__] and she needed something to wear
you think like he was like wear my shirt
for the album cup like it was like
calculated no like maybe they were like
hanging out and she wanted like you know
with a big group and they all went
swimming and he's like you know here
take a shirt and she has it at her house
like I don't know okay even if that's
what happened like that's the start of
like a little romance but also based on
some of my research his song Tennessee
fan has been written for a few years
um and it's not like a direct response
to her song that went viral called
Tennessee orange got it well I was
listening to her album there's a song on
it called
let me pull it up because I really think
it's about Morgan Wallen and I want you
guys to let me know why or why not it's
called um why Johnny and it's like about
it's her like basically asking June
Carter Cash like why Johnny Cash like
with all of his issues and stuff and I
feel like she feels that way about
Morgan Wallen that like he's her Johnny
Cash and like and so she's asking June
for like guidance like how can you
choose this person when they're like
really so troubled
okay that could be but it also like I
could see it you know she's a girl who
grew up in the South who grew up
listening to country music probably
idolized June and Johnny
um and maybe she's like you know fanfic
role-playing in her head like I don't
know if yeah it could be I think that's
also feasible it could be nothing but I
do feel like she it was analogous June
and Johnny Megan and Morgan and like how
did you make it work why him like even
when he was making it so hard for you
where I imagine Morgan's not an easy
person to love sure no I could
definitely see it but I could also see
somebody you know watching Walk the Line
and then writing that song you know it's
it's a it's kind of a it's not a crazy
question you know June why yeah
why Johnny it just it hits different
when it's like someone else who's
falling in love with like an uh a
troubled country music star yeah and
that like really like the biggest he's
like you know so popular yeah no I see
it but I could also not see it you know
for sure well now she's saying she won't
tell us who anything is about anymore
her new song sleep on my side she said
it's not a nice song so she certainly
won't be saying who that's about
asleep on my side and you sleep with
everyone
fact Acts
facts
I really should I actually don't [__]
why
I love this you know speculation for for
Megan things like this are so good for a
young country starlet's career so I love
the the speculation the conversations
being had about it I think it's all good
for business but as an actual couple
like I just don't [__]
think of the music
no I'm thinking think about a duet
they could still do a duet if they're
not they could be George and Tammy
they could June and Johnny
they could girth Tim and Faith
Tim and Faith
Kelsey and Morgan
rip
we need good like I'm just saying
if you think about the history of like
country music couples like we're true
for a new
yeah cause I guess like the the most
recent is like Tim and Faith right
the youngest Miranda and Blake would
have been
but they're not anymore yeah I know but
neither would you by the way George and
Tammy were literally together for six
minutes
oh the six years but still then she'd
literally married someone for 20. so
oh bye yeah but it was not good
I guess you should need like more more
matriarch patriarch
of country music latriarch
late tricks
so I'll just keep shipping over here and
in the meantime are you ready for our
fifth and final story wow that like just
really crept up on me yeah Apple will
stop auto correcting the swear word to
ducking on your iPhone so I think that's
great I think that is so great and thank
you so much for doing that 10 years
later I I couldn't have asked for it
anything it's more than 10 years it's
literally like when did iPhone come out
yeah I guess I've had an iPhone like
since
like high school yeah so in all those
years if you want to say [__] you're
gonna say ducking until your phone gets
used to you
but now finally Apple will let us curse
in peace they announced a ton of new
stuff at their
Apple Expo that they do every year and
usually it's just like a new pair of
airpods and like a bigger or smaller
iPad but there's was a lot that they
announced I know you guys talked about
the FaceTime voicemail which for me is
the future I'm obsessed obsessed we've
needed it for so long like it's it's
annoying that like we had to wait for it
but
but I'm happy that it's here knowing I'm
legitimately like frightened of the
person I'm gonna become when that
feature comes out like I will abuse the
absolute [__] of it especially like if
I've had a cocktail oh my God same but
it was gonna be so good for you because
you always FaceTime me and when I don't
pick up you forget where you were gonna
say so you could just like you could
just drop a word and then and then I'll
call you back and I'll be like you said
this
and I'll be like oh yeah here's a piece
of tea I found out right so I'm excited
about that they also drop their VR
headset and we were just talking about
like how do you get into the metaverse
how do you participate and I feel like
apple dropping the headgear is gonna
direct response is it gonna bring a lot
of more people into the metaverse
unfortunately
and people people are really shook by
the price it's 3 500 which I don't know
VR so I don't know if that's like a
Market Fair Price
well I don't know what other goggles
cost but like think about what a phone
costs and now you like
and also if you're in the metaverse like
isn't the goggles then like your
apartment too
yeah so it's right your toilet like and
your car yeah it's kind of a bargain for
a whole year old I always find these
like apple Summits really interesting
but I just know that once that Summit
comes out because they always announce
like a new iPhone and stuff all of my
Apple products will start to become
defunct so like the second they got off
that stage like all my apps started not
working all my products that are not
like the most up-to-date versions have
started to like spark and just
completely shut down so that's kind of
annoying that is annoying but did they
announce new iPhone stuff or like maybe
the iPhone is safe for now I don't know
because I was thinking about I need a
new phone it's just like started the
second the second you don't have the
most recent version they start to like
crap out on you so that you get it it's
like they press a button at Apple HQ oh
we have a new iPhone available break all
the former versions and it's like they
literally give you no choice so I was
thinking I'm like there must be a new
iPhone because that whole Apple thing
happened so I'm not going to get a new
phone to that one actually comes out
yeah
right there's nothing worse than getting
a new phone and then Apple like just
launches their new version like you know
15f but this is the new version is not
there's nothing new about it you know
there were some there are some like
tangible differences like when we went
from like two camera lenses to three and
it's like oh [__] I just bought a two
and there's a three on the market but
right now like the new phones they
haven't actually really made a change in
a while so you're fine
another feature that got people really
talking was like this new accessibility
feature where it's a really modified
home screen it just has like calling
text messages and camera so really good
for you know older people and all the
icons are huge and I actually thought
that was really smart that's cool yeah
it doesn't look for your grandma
groundbreaking technology no it's just
it's nice no it's nice but like I feel
like an app could have provided you know
what I mean you could like organize for
sure to look like that
for sure you get to change your app
sizes and stuff I'm just I'm happy for
Grant is that okay yeah no that's okay
I'm just saying that I feel like that
wasn't very Innovative of them and I'm
trying to get them to innovate but I do
think that this was the most Innovative
Expo in a while with those VR headsets
FaceTime voicemail they're really trying
to cater to the people yeah but you saw
have you seen the zoom on the Samsung
Galaxy
I have I saw the Moon
I didn't see the moon oh somebody was
like showing you the difference between
zooming in on the moon on an iPhone and
zooming on the food on the moon zooming
in on the moon with a Samsung and like
the Samsung it actually looks like a
telescope it's the craziest thing no I
sent you a video a few weeks ago of it
was a picture of a truck license plate
yes and then it zooms out all the way
and it literally is taken from like 50
miles away Samsung Galaxy you should get
one and why don't we
as a p as a people
get Samsung Galaxies like
yeah no it's like a known fact that
Samsung Galaxies and Androids in general
have better features our better phones
have all these things that Apple comes
out with and everybody like shits their
pants they're like you know we've been
able to do this on an Android for six
months right like they're like Apple
Android is living in the future but
there is a cool factor of it's a status
symbol Apple and they're just cooler
that's plain and simple and that's why
everybody spends insane amounts of money
Androids are also cheaper like there's
literally no reason we shouldn't all be
walking around with Androids yeah no
we're all a bunch of fools
fools who got played by like marketing
yeah or maybe someone could tell me like
what are the pros I'm sure there are
things that Apple has that Android
doesn't
right the Blue Tech iMessage that's
literally it
what if I started texting you and I was
Green
I wouldn't text you like that's the
thing it's so beyond it we couldn't
FaceTime
we would need Whatsapp
oh is that true is FaceTime only Apple
to Apple yeah I guess yeah
that's all I use my phone for I'm a
FaceTime right now I'm on FaceTime right
now if my phone stops making like
regular phone calls I probably wouldn't
notice until I had to call 9-1-1 yeah
because you also can make Wi-Fi calls
like anywhere I will say the person who
came up with the FaceTime voicemail
feature is obviously the same person
that came up with the we're sending a
code to your phone and then it
automatically populates and you don't
even have to open the text message that
person is the same person as the
FaceTime voicemail it's the person who
came up with the code thing like isn't a
billionaire living in a mansion on a
hill by the Sea then I don't want it
like that person with the person
deserves the Nobel Peace Prize same for
the person who created the unsubscribe
button in apple in mail yeah
that's a pretty genius one that is a
civil servant
no that's quite literally what we should
what we're technically paying for like
that sort of Ingenuity literally
ease of use
ease of use ease of use
so those were the Fast Five
true correct correct
um tomorrow's episode is Jax Taylor I
really hope you guys enjoy it you'll be
able to listen and to watch and then
next week we're gonna do you know
similar to what we did this week a mix
of Jackson Claude hybrid only a hybrid
hopefully we get some fabulous people in
studio and of course I have nothing
planned but you know me Sunday is my day
for organizing everything because I got
to be the most annoying person on the
planet
hey can you podcast with me tomorrow
like I'm so annoying
um so let me know who you want to see uh
we love you guys dearly thank you so
much for listening to The Chosen Monday
Morning Show we deliver the past five
stories in each and every threatening
YouTubes are watching the new
duplications
amazing day amazing weekend and enjoy
tomorrow's episode and we'll see you
back on Monday love you bye